guess what it's gonna go pretty well
it's gonna be a lot of ups and downs I'm
not going to tell you the specifics
because you get too scared so just
appreciate Where You Are
well how many times did you hit bottom
would you say uh how many grains of sand
in the desert sir yeah but you never
know when it's going to be your time in
the barrel and and I've been on both
sides of that coin I need to be kept uh
right sized because I can easily fall
into
self-seeking and depression and
self-pity and judgment and all that
stuff it's kind of a
it's a bit of a default but I spend
enough energy and I've had enough uh
help over enough years to actually just
say oh that's that's just
awful destructive behavior when you're
25 and you're given the keys to the
kingdom you're going to probably come
out of Center maybe out of fear maybe
out of confidence
when things finally started catching up
with me being able to learn Implement
and not as my dad always says kid make
new mistakes
once I was able to make new mistakes
which was in my uh late 30s
completely different ball game it
baffles me confidence what is what does
it really mean there was a period of
time where
I felt like I did uh I did the first
Iron Man and then I was doing the first
Sherlock and I had my shirt off and I'm
saying martial I was like I was all over
the place and it just felt like I was I
was hitting triples no matter what I did
and um and then people are like are you
really as confident as you seem and I
was like I guess right now I am yeah
there's been times when I felt I'm in
possession of it and then you want to
let go a little bit because it's only
ever the moment in life
guiding you the wind is so at your back
that you're like wow are you just are
you just you know jumping over the waves
and all that by yourself and you're like
you bet I am but there's a physics to
the moment man moment machine whatever
and the wins at your back and then the
wind does what wind does and it changes
and if you're left there thinking what
you know so I think it's great to be in
full possession of what you would call
Supreme confidence and then see what
happens if you don't hold on to it so
hard because it's great but it is a bit
of an illusion because like everything
else it's always changing and every day
the reset button the space bar gets
pressed and it's like now what prison
culture is really uh something that's
hard to explain it's opened my eyes to a
lot things are are violent and there's
certain things that you do when you
enter that system that you wouldn't care
to do on the street but it's part of the
deal there's a morality Clause here on
on this planet and it's a big price to
pay and I think having a moral
psychology is uh is job one
so sometimes you just got to go yeah you
know
I effed up actually I asked Mel to
present uh this award to me for a reason
because when I couldn't get sober he
told me not to give up hope and he urged
me to find my faith
didn't have to be his or anyone else's
as long as it was rooted in forgiveness
and I couldn't get hired so he cast me
in the lead of a movie that was actually
developed for him and he kept a roof
over my head and he kept food on the
table
and most importantly he said that if I
accepted responsibility for my
wrongdoings and if I embrace that
part of my soul that was ugly hugging
the cactus he calls it he said that if I
hug the cactus long enough I'd become a
man of some humility
and that my life would take on a new
meaning
and I did and it worked all he asked in
return
was that someday I helped the next guy
in some small way
little things are easy to change Big
Things become a inconvenience to the
higher good and at what point do you
want to pull the air brake on something
where the trains you know already
leaving the station it's really
difficult and the more stressed out I
think anyone is the more they try to
bring their own world view to Bear to
soothe themselves and to try to fit in
but it's the this question to me is the
only question that that I feel I need to
keep asking myself
can you get quiet enough to actually
connect with the other flailing human
beings that are actually trying to do
something valid together if I'm noticing
anything now it's that it's that we need
to shift and we need new challenges and
just like
MMA and society and politics things are
moving and morphing and the information
age is making things so everything's
learning and growing from everything so
quickly and improving or disproving or
or uh discounting whatever's happening
next well I was talking to my shrink on
the ride down here today and as usual
the topic of the day is the topic it
always is which is we don't really know
what we're doing when we're doing it and
if we get comfortable with that then
we're going to be less shocked by the
awful results yeah you know so
I here's all I'll say you want to talk
about validation and mentors and and
people who have been with me at critical
times I mentioned some male directors
all of them together could not hold the
candle to the power of partnership
when you find somebody who without
meaning to you just kind of get each
other and then you kind of you cash you
cash in all your chips and you say we're
going to do this difficult thing which
is called relationship building and I
might have been dead as a doornail in
Ojai if I hadn't met her who knows
because she's the only person in my
entire life and career who I can nail it
on a take
I need to be taken care of I need to be
validated in my personal life I try to
be this as a dad without being rigid I
try to just hold my space so that it's
something that is consistent enough for
someone else to rely on and have a deep
abiding trusted if I'm completely uh
trustworthy if my word is bond and if I
suit up and show up no matter what and
you can count on me that gives the
others so much freedom because they're
not having to entangle with my
inconsistency or my neurosis